I
wonder if there's a café with a market, no, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Tell Greg about threats and pickpockets [music]
That junk is on the verge of exploding.
That's the numbers
, I can only say that it's working well in this state
Is it a
delusional state
?  Please take it from
Wow,
did Buzz receive my words? It's
a rust that came out of
your
body.
But my heart hurts
, the group is about to die in an explosion, oh
come on
, I'm driving you into a corner Show me your power
This is the end It's
time limit
ana I'm a record boy
do you paint yeah
[music]